After I took the SAT I was so exhausted I
wanted to sleep for days, but I just sat there
for hours, how can sitting there and THINKING,
wear you out?
Hey Brainiacs, Julia here for DNews
Have you ever been really tired after spending
all day sitting around at school?
How can you be so exhausted from literally
just sitting all day?
Why is learning so tiring?
Well let’s start with the body’s energy
usage, 30% of the calories you eat go to maintaining
your current muscle mass.
While our brain only makes up 2% of your body
weight, it gobbles up 20% of the energy you
take in.
One study published in Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences USA found that
2/3s of the energy the brain uses goes to
the firing of cells.
But the other third, is basically just brain
maintenance.
So where does that energy come from?
Most of the energy the brain eats up is in
the form of glucose from the things we eat.
When neurons fire, they need extra oxygen
and glucose from nearby capillaries.
So scientists think that when performing a
difficult mental task, the neurons would eat
up more glucose.
And so there’d be less glucose in the blood
stream if you’d measure it after something
like a tiring test.
And that’s what some studies show.
Another study published in the journal Physiology
Behavior found that there was less blood glucose
in the bloodstream, which the researchers
thought was linked to neurons firing on all
cylinders.
Another more recent study published in Human
Factors: The Journal of the Human Factors
and Ergonomics Society found that people get
more exhausted when exerting both physical
and mental faculties than when just simply
working out.
The researchers specifically noted that when
performing both physical and mental tasks,
there was strong activity in the prefrontal
cortex and there was lower blood oxygen levels
in the PFC after a combined physical and mental
task than when just doing physical work.
So following that line of thought, eating
foods high in glucose should improve performance.
One review published in the European Journal
of Pharmacology found that glucose can improve
memory, but it depends on the dose and the
person.
So there is something about mental tasks that
makes our brains work a little harder and
use up a little more glucose.
But does it actually make us tired?
Well results are mixed.
One small study published in the journal Psychosomatic
Medicine found that people who just completed
memorization and attention tests ate 200 more
calories than those just relaxed.
But… it might be more than just brain drain.
One scientist, Claude Messier of the University
of Ottawas, thinks maybe it’s just stress,
that those students were just stress eating.
Which is a very real thing.
So while test taking might be zapping your
energy, maybe it’s the classroom you’re
in.
Matt Lieberman explains how Carbon dioxide
in the classroom might make for slower brains.